L Rock approach Cheroke 7348
Juliet Cheroke 7348 Juliet L Rock
approach a lot of Pilots are intimidated
by air traffic control but it shouldn't
be that way these guys are here to help
us and make it safer to fly airplanes so
today I'm going to show you the stuff
you need so you can use ATC effectively
and be safe when you fly jul
0217 call sa position
ATC helps us avoid other aircraft by
using radar but radar technology is
limited so we use transponders to make
it easier for them to see us and they
also give them some other information
like altitude so they can help us avoid
a collision this transponder is a little
bit newer model but they all basically
work about the same take a look at this
four-digit code on the display screen
this is what we call the transponder
code also known as the code on
this particular model you can change
your squat code by pushing these numbers
on the keypad at the bottom of the
transponder but on older models these
numbers are changed by rotating little
round dials for each individual number
okay so which code do we need to use
well under normal visual flight rules we
need to be squawking 1 1200 or you could
also get a transponder code assigned
from ATC and they would give it to you
if you were getting services like flight
following or if you in class Bravo class
Charlie or in a TSA in other words busy
airspace where ATC is watching you on
radar let me show you real quick what
that might sound like which to approach
skyw 1 2 3 4 POA three nautical miles
north of Cheney Dam 2500 inbound with
Tango Skyhawk
234 approach
0114 okay before I respond to this guy I
just want to point out the fact that now
we have our squat code and this is going
to allow him to find us a lot easier and
not only that but he can match up the
code with our call sign and he can keep
track of us as we're flying to the
Airfield
011 and now I can type in that code
using these keys I talked about earlier
and that's what's going to make it
easier for him to find us but sometimes
if he's monitoring a lot of airplanes or
he's covering a big area he might still
have a hard time finding you if that
happens you might hear this radio
Calla if you hear this you don't need to
respond on the radio all you have to do
is push this button right here that says
ident and what this will do is it'll
send him a text message so he knows
you're serious about coming in for a
landing I'm just messing with you it
basically just highlights your airplane
on his radar screen okay so then once he
does find you you're going to hear the
words radar contact and then they'll
usually give you some instructions or
something after
that radar contact six miles Northwest
of witto make right BAS for
righta okay so let's talk about some
other squa codes that you might need to
use when you're in the airplane the
first one of these is 7700 and you would
type this in anytime you're having an
emergency in the airplane an emergency
can mean a lot of different things it
can mean an engine failure engine fire
smoke in the cockpit basically anything
that you think might keep you from
getting to the runway but if you're
having an emergency not only do you need
to squat 7700 but you also need to
declare the emergency and you would do
this on the frequency
121.5 this is also called guard an easy
way I found to remember this frequency
is to think of Dr EMT Brown from Back to
the Future remember 1.21 gigawatts and
as long as you can remember the five
after that you'll never forget this all
right let me show you what it might
sound like to declare an emergency so
you can practice on your own May
Maya just experienced anine failure
milest of
Soul get enough information out there so
they can send a rescue party to your
Landing location but keep it brief so
you can focus on flying the airplane
we'll focus more on this in a future
lesson so don't worry about that with
all that in mind if you're already
talking with ATC and they've already
given you a code you don't need to
squawk 7700 and you don't need to switch
over to
121.5 you just need to declare the
emergency and leave your squawk exactly
what it is here's what that might sound
like on the
[Music]
radios onard request vectors to the
nearest rway at this point your airplane
has priority over all other airplanes
and from now on your call sign is
Skyhawk 1234 Papa emergency now I do
want to mention that normally you would
tell them how much fuel you have on
board but in this case I don't know
because I have a fuel leak and from here
on out they're going to do the best they
can to help us make a safe landing
somewhere just remember fly the airplane
first and talk to those guys as you can
another squat code that might come in
handy if your radio quits working is
7600 and this is the code that you'd put
in your transponder if you lost
Communications with ATC if this happens
to you under visual flight rules and
you're in an area that requires two-way
radio communication the FAA says that
you need to land as soon as practicable
I know what you're thinking nobody even
uses this word anymore but that's the
word it uses in section 4 the Aim so I
take that to mean that I can land at the
airport I originally intended on Landing
at in this case it's Witchita make sure
you pick a Runway favored by the wind so
today we'll use one nine right then once
we start getting close to the field
we'll start looking for light gun
signals from the tower and this is how
we're going to get our clearance to land
in a second we'll talk about what those
are but if you get one of these signals
to let them know you got it during the
day you can either rock your wings or
wag your tail and just in case there's
any doubt I'm talking about moving your
r back and forth I really doubt if you
have a physical tail ATC is going to be
able to see you wagging that then at
night you can acknowledge receipt by
either flashing your Landing or your
navigation lights all right so let's
talk about those light gun signals for
just a minute as you can see here
there's actually quite a few different
meanings for the different light gun
signals you may see but in this video
I'm only going to talk about how the
light gun signals apply to aircraft in
Flight if you want to see how they apply
to vehicles or aircraft on the ground
you can find this table in the aim in
chapter four the first light gun signal
that you might see is a flashing red
light if you see this this means the
airport is unsafe don't land if you see
a steady red light like this that means
you should give way to other aircraft
and continue circling if I was in this
situation and I got the signal from
Tower I probably just do a couple turns
around a point right where I'm at until
I get another signal from them next we
have the flashing green light and this
simply means to return for a landing and
this is probably the one you'd see if
you got the flashing red light and then
you're out there circling for a little
while and they were trying to bring you
back in you might also get this one if
you need to go around for some reason
then the flashing green light should be
followed by a steady green light which
means cleared to land then the last one
you might see is alternating red and
green like this and that just means to
exercise Extreme Caution and to be
honest I'm really not sure when you
would see this one maybe if they were
trying to warn you about wake turbulence
or wind shear or something now that
you've got that down let's talk about
that last quat code that I hope nobody
ever has to use and that's 7500 and this
is the code that you want to type in if
you were experiencing a hijacking if you
use this squat code ATC is required to
verify that you intended to squawk 7500
if you confirm that you did intend to do
it from there they will notify the
authorities follow the flight and
respond to all the Pilot's requests
before we continue our discussion on ATC
let's talk about some of the other
buttons you might see on your
transponder some of the newer
transponders like this one has some
additional buttons that the old one
don't have like these over here these
buttons allow you to control the extra
features of your transponder by using
these you can cycle through the pressure
altitude reading you see here maybe a
digital timer and a couple other gadgets
that you might find Handy in flight but
they're not required over here we have
the main controls which should be on
every transponder and you should be
familiar with now we already talked
about the ENT button in the center there
and the off button is pretty obvious but
check out this little button label VFR
if your transponder has one of these and
you push this button you don't have to
go through the agony of typing in one
12000 it automatically types it in for
you as Lenny pepper bottom would say
that's pretty neat now the on button
applies electrical power to the entire
transponder but this standby button
turns off the signal going to ATC but
leaves your transponder on you may be
asked to do this on the ground at
certain airports and it's kind of hard
on the equipment to turn the entire
transponder off then back on and this
button just keeps you from having to do
that that next we have the most
important button on the entire
transponder and that's this out button
right here if you forget what all the
other buttons on the transponder do this
is the one you need to remember and
that's because it turns on the mode C in
your transponder and mode C is what
reports our pressure altitude to air
traffic control and if you remember we
need to have our transponder on and
Reporting our mode C altitude over to
air traffic control in certain airspaces
do you remember what those are first of
all we need to either have a mode three
a or a mode s transponder and these need
to have that altitude reporting
capability anytime we go into class
Alpha airspace class Bravo above and
within 30 miles of class Bravo class
Charlie and above class Charlie and
anytime we go above 10,000 ft MSL I also
want to mention that if you want to go
into any of these airspaces you also
need adsb out and this equipment uses
satellite technology instead of radar to
track your airplane this gives air
traffic control a lot more accurate
picture of where your airplane is and
maybe eventually it will completely
replace the transponder technology but
for now you still need to know how to
use it and where it's required next
let's take a look at some of the
services offered by air traffic control
before we do if you're enjoying this
video please consider subscribing and
hitting the Bell notification I've got
lots more great training coming and I
don't want you to miss out on those
videos but anyways here's some of those
Services ATC offers flight following
safety alerts limited radar vectoring
sequencing and separation from other
aircraft flight following which is also
called radar traffic information service
is a courtesy service offered by air
traffic control and that just means as
long as their workload is permitting
they can offer you some different things
like traffic advisories safety alerts
and sometimes radar vectors and we'll
talk about those more here in just a
second but this is something you can ask
for anytime you're in controlled
airspace and sometimes class golf as
long as they can see you on radar so now
you're probably wondering well what
exactly is flight following I like to
call it IFR light but the truth is all
it is is ATC following you on radar and
helping you watch for other aircraft
let's say we took off from this small
airport near witcho called Newton County
let's see if we can get VFR flight
following over to Hutchinson by calling
Witchita approach witch approach skyw 2
3 4 Papa 3 nautical miles west of Newton
County Airport kilo Echo whiskey kilo
2,500 request VFR flight following to
Hutchinson kilo Hotel uniform Tango
Skyhawk
papa1
123123 Sky two3 Papa Skyhawk 1234 Papa
radar contact 3 miles west of Newton
County huderson
al8 28 n skyw 2 3 Papa all right so now
that we're on flight following with
approach let's check out some of the
things we might see first we have
traffic advisories and these are only
given as long as the controller's work
situation permits and these are going to
be given to you based on the positions
of hours on a clock now imagine that
you're looking down at the top of your
airplane with the clock going all the
way around it with 12:00 in the front
and 6:00 in the back now let's say
you're on a Northbound heading this is
what a traffic advisory is going to
sound like Sky 2 3 4 Papa traffic
2:00 8000 now we're looking for traffic
in line with this 2:00 position 10 miles
out and they'll be at 8,000 ft heading
in the opposite direction because we're
Northbound and they're southbound and as
you can see these are pretty simple but
just to make sure you got the concept
I'll show you one more now let's say
we're on an easterly
heading
34A traffic 11:00 5 mil 4500 now let's
draw that imaginary line out from our
aircraft through the 11:00 position and
that's where we should be looking for
that traffic at 4,500 ft now there is a
small chance that you could get asked
how many degrees off the nose is this
traffic just remember every hour
represents 30° so in this case this
traffic is 30° to the left of the nose
something else ATC can offer you are
safety alerts these are mandatory for
ATC to give you when you're under radar
Services basically if they think you're
getting a little too close to the
terrain rain or an obstruction they
should be alerting you key word there is
should with these they should also alert
you if they think that an airplane is
getting so close to you that it's unsafe
the aim says that they will offer the
pilot an alternative course of action
guys I just want to point out that air
traffic control is usually awesome at
their job but ultimately the
responsibility of not hitting other
airplanes rests solely on you so make
sure you keep your eyes outside next for
VFR traffic we can request limited radar
vectoring limited just means these guys
are super busy use it sparingly I might
use this if I got myself lost or
something it's better to arrive a shame
than to get yourself lost and crash
[Music]
somewhere
rad next we have sequencing and this is
something you usually get in class Bravo
or Charlie airspace basically this just
means taking all the different aircraft
coming from different directions and
lining them up so they can land on the
runway and they do this through radar
vectors and by having you follow the
airplane in front of you which by the
way if they tell you to do that then
they give the guy in front of you
clearance to land that doesn't mean you
also have the clearance to land that
just means follow them you still have to
get your own clearance and that brings
us to a discussion on spacing in class
Bravo airspace ATC gives you spacing
between between bfr and IFR aircraft
usually they'll keep you separated by
500 ft vertically tell you spot the
other aircraft then once you advise him
that you have that traffic inside you
should hear this
mpar then once you hear that the spacing
is basically on you until you land on
the runway in class Charlie airspace
it's really similar they still give you
the 500t vertical separation but they
only give you that separation from IFR
aircraft they won't give you any kind of
separation from another VFR aircraft so
if you're not paying attention you could
be right next to somebody there's
actually quite a bit more to talk about
as far as separation goes in the aim in
chapter three and section two if you
have time you should consider reading
that but this is what I think you need
to know to get ready for your check ride
and your written exam now if you enjoyed
this video and you'd like to get better
at radio communications try this video
right here if you've already watched
that one try this one right here I made
this one so you can practice those Radio
Calls thanks for watching s